all right we have two positive donald
trump stories today they are good
stories they are things that are good
for the left they are things that are
good for the country they are things
that are good for the world and for
everything that is good the first one is
uh monday you might remember i told you
that donald trump filed before a judge
named tanya chutkin had even made a
decision about donald trump's first
request to block documents and records
related to his activities leading up to
the trump riots from being sent to the
committee investigating the trump riots
before the judge even ruled on the first
one
donald trump already submitted a second
request saying no no you got here's
another reason why you should block this
stuff
and i told you on monday we are waiting
for a decision from judge tanya chutkin
we now have gotten a decision i guess we
would call it the first decision and the
decision is the correct one it's a good
one and it is that uh judge chutkin has
denied donald trump's attempt to
withhold records from the january 6th
committee to put it very simply as cnn
explains a federal judge will allow the
u.s house to access hundreds of pages of
documents from donald trump's presidency
leading up to and about the january 6th
attack at the u.s capitol in a forceful
rejection of trump's recent attempts to
control information from his white house
the ruling tuesday night from judge
tania chutkin of the u.s district court
in dc is a blow to trump's efforts to
keep more than 700 pages of records from
the white house secret though his legal
team has informed the court it it tends
to appeal
presidents are not kings and plaintiff
is not president
um a very interesting final page from
the decision which you can easily find
online uh judge chutkin writes
accordingly the court holds that the
public interest lies in permitting the
combined will of the legislative and
executive branches to study the events
that led to and occurred on january 6
and to consider legislation to prevent
such events from occurring again
judge chutkin's conclusion is for the
reasons explained above
the court will deny plaintiff's request
to enjoin defendants from enforcing or
complying with the select committees
august 25 2021 requests because
plaintiff is unlikely to succeed on the
merits of his claims or suffer
irreparable harm and because a balance
of the equities and public interest bear
against granting his requested relief
so the um let's go back to the cnn
article
as of now
the national archives remains on track
to turn over to the house a number of
documents
friday now as i've told you before this
includes white house call logs and video
logs who was trump speaking to
in those days leading up to the riots
and schedules related to january 6. who
was trump meeting with at the white
house as well as three pages of
handwritten notes from trump's then
chief of staff the outcome in court also
could help the house in its pursuit of
more information from those around trump
including witnesses who haven't been
subpoenaed and haven't spoken to the
committee yet what that means is knowing
who trump spoke to knowing who trump met
with will give the house investigators
more information about hey here are
people trump spoke to let's go and talk
to them let's subpoena them let's
request their records now important note
two important notes i guess i would say
one scheduled for release friday
to the committee
so there's two things there one
scheduled for release friday it's only
wednesday between now and then donald
trump may try
more funny business and uh he his lawyer
is saying that they're going to make
another appeal
so will the documents actually be
released to the house committee friday
we don't yet really know the second part
is
released to the committee and i'm
continuing to get emails from folks
understandably excited about these
documents saying when are we going to
see them we may never see them because
again it is released to the committee
released to the committee and um
documents sometimes leak and sometimes
are deliberately leaked it's completely
conceivable that by next monday we will
have a leaked call log of the people
trump spoke to or a visitor log of the
people trump met with in the days
leading up to the january six riots at
the same time that's not actually what
is at issue here this is about releasing
these documents to the committee not to
the public last thing
this will probably
not come as a surprise to you
but um well so
this part may be a surprise to you the
judge here judge tanya chutkin is
jamaican by origin that you may not have
known
the part that probably wouldn't surprise
you is
the things that are being said by
trumpists
about judge chutkin
on the basis that she's jamaican okay if
you go and look at the typical trumpest
enclaves of the internet and this
includes you know pick your pick your
enclave facebook comments of course
youtube comments
certain subreddits on reddit
twitter
parlor getter i don't even know if
getter is still around um
there are many trumpists
focused on judge chutkin's jamaican
origin
as a
flashpoint of anger
and something to blame for her decision
here
um of course absent any evidence of that
and some may even call that xenophobic
or racist some may you know that's
something i'm reading
um we're going gonna follow what the
substance of the trump appeal is and
we'll know friday or certainly by monday
whether the committee investigating the
riots has gotten this information
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
that specializes in documentaries i
watch curiosity stream on my tv phone
and computer curiosity stream always has
so many titles i can't find on netflix
hulu or amazon a much better selection
of documentaries than any of those
platforms documentaries on science
nature history politics tech music
psychology i just finished watching
man's first friend tremendous film about
dogs or dogs as some say if you love
documentaries and learning curiosity
stream is something you must have they
always have the newest most critically
acclaimed titles
and curiosity stream is giving my
audience that's you
25 off a subscription which comes out to
just 15 bucks a year go to
curiositystream.com pacman the link is
down below